pj how are you i'm fabulous how are you
fantastic um what was it like joining
the world of the proud family
um it was amazing i mean like i grew up
watching it you know i think the series
came out when i was about like nine
eight or nine
so
you know i loved it then
and um you know it was just so cool to
be a part of this like reboot because
it's like you know it's such an iconic
show and especially you know being a
young person like you know growing up
watching it like it's really cool to
like be a part of this reimagining
process and so
when um
ralph came to me you know with you know
their vision for michael and what they
wanted them to look like and you know i
was just like oh my god this is this is
perfect this is fabulous and um you know
so we just you know got in there and
made some magic and it was so much fun
um so when you were when you were nine
and you were watching this did you put
the connection together between
wizard kelly and your dad
oh yeah obviously okay
it was obvious and that was like a
running joke you know and like
the you know his wife is named uh ginger
snap and my mom's name is cookie so like
i mean yeah right we all knew that yes
but what was that like what was that
like in the house growing up like was it
was it flattery was he cool with it did
you goof on him for it like what was
what was the sort of vibe around that
um
i don't even remember i don't know if i
don't remember talking to him about it i
knew my mom knew and like she thought it
was funny because like ralph has been a
friend of our family you know forever so
um you know obviously like he did that
in in you know in jess because you know
they're all friends but like i honestly
don't even remember talking to my dad
about it
i don't even think yeah i'm not sure
that we even brought up
uh when it comes to uh when it comes to
michael how much of you and your own
insight were you allowed to sort of
bring to
bring to bring to michael because this
is a character that is relatively new on
on on in animation in cartoons on
television in show business in general
um
a lot i brought you know all of my
myself uh to this character and they
really wanted that you know and like i
remember when we were talking about you
know you know
the kind of like the clothes and the
gender fluidity of the fashion i was
like are they really gonna let you do
this like i was like i mean i'm down but
like is disney really gonna let you do
this and they're like i don't know but
we're gonna you know we're gonna really
push and so you know
in working with glad and you know going
back and forth with the network like it
was beautiful that they you know let the
character rock and be themselves um i
think one of the main important things
for me especially knowing that
you know
coming from that perspective of being a
young person watching this show and
knowing that young people are watching
this and you know being
being able to see themselves represented
in this character i wanted to bring all
of the confidence and all of the um
you know self-worth and self-love and
power that i experience as an adult to
this you know character because
you know that's how you know you really
wanted to be you know in that age as a
teenager and you know so it's kind of
cool to see this character you know with
all this kind of like all the you know
the beauty the beautiful things i
experienced as an adult and that i've
experienced it over the years and coming
to terms with myself as a young person
it's just really cool to see and like
wow like when i was watching the first
two episodes i was like okay like this
character's everything because you know
i was able to throw everything that i
have at this character and like you know
it's cool to see them as a young person
but with all of the vibrance that you
know come with
growing up in age and you know just
becoming more fabulous and comfortable
in your own skin so it's wonderful
michael is sort of this fabulous light
and a sea of teenage awkwardness yes and
like a teenage angst and you know i mean
that's just a difficult time for all of
us i mean we can all look back in those
years and be like ugh
like high school was just and like yeah
exactly like you said like to see that
ray of light and just a character who's
just fabulous unapologetic and like
carefree and fearless it's like that's
what i would have wanted when i was in
high school like that's what it is
yeah and the the age you are now getting
to do this because it wasn't
even that long ago or even having a gay
couple in an animated show you could
sort of do it but you had to tiptoe
around it we could assume they were but
nobody would really say they were and
then you look at what you get to be a
part of now at the age you are now sort
of you know this has to be like almost
like a dream for for a performer
um absolutely and you know just for you
know being you know
living my life and being you know
loving my own life and comfortable my
own skin like it's really you know
beautiful to bring that to a character
but also to open the doors you know
because we like he said like we need to
see more diversity you know in
characters in shows because like we
don't have
much and you know to work for such a you
know a powerful institution like disney
you know it's great because
you know i'm really excited to see more
doors on their side open especially with
all the live-action movies they're doing
in the superhero movies and like there's
just so much opportunity to see these
characters played out and i'm excited to
you know continue to work with them and
you know play more characters
uh like that you know similar to this
and who are just like themselves like
it's always been my dream to be a disney
villain so like you know like when i was
growing up i only wanted to be ursula or
like the evil queen or corella de ville
so
um i'm excited to see you know
characters like that being born and and
coming in and being written into shows
and movies and stuff and like it's gonna
be really it's really exciting to be on
the forefront of a new movement so it's
great
thank you so much thanks for doing the
interview in a proper throne i really
appreciate your time thank you nice to
meet you very good to meet you take it
easy